JENNY BROWN: Are
you stuck looking
for a sweet spot between
user connection speed,
cloud hosting performance,
and the buffer window
you use request data?
Well, you're in luck.
Because today on
"Cloud Storage bytes,"
we're exploring the Venn
diagram that is performance,
and we're going to
find that overlap.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're a company
that streams data,
performance for
you and your users
is going to be a
reasonably huge priority.
Let's say you're
a company that's
looking to duplicate
your content
for an international audience.
Your architecture
setup is pretty simple,
currently serving data directly
from Google Cloud Storage
to users on mobile and desktop.
Let's take a look at how you can
go about optimizing your window
size, so you can
ensure consistent
buffering to all
of your clients,
no matter where they are.
To make sure we're
on the right track,
we'll need to profile how
the read performance adjusts
at various window
sizes of download.
You can test this by
writing a small script.
Create a regional bucket,
create a bunch of files
at a bunch of
sizes, upload them,
and download each file 100
times via an HTTP fetch request
with caching disabled.
If you run this
script, you'll see
that there are consistent
results for files
smaller than 1 megabyte,
which we already
knew from previous episodes.
And if you run it again,
but tweak it slightly using
a larger file, fetch
through different chunks,
you'll see that as
chunk size decreases,
the transactional overhead
increases and slows everything
down.
As we know already,
Google Cloud Storage
is very powerful in
terms of single stream
throughput and write
throughput, meaning
that for both uploads
and downloads,
Google Cloud Storage is
optimally utilized for requests
that are no smaller
than 1 megabyte in size.
Otherwise, that all too
familiar transactional overhead
is going to bog
things down again.
With this information,
you can better
determine what level
of regional redundancy
is needed for serving
your video content.
And you can optimize for the 1
meg plus Google Cloud Storage
target to improve
your buffering speeds.
There's plenty more to come
about optimizing performance,
but we're going to go ahead
and save that for another time.
If you want to know more,
go ahead and check out
the links in the description.
And don't forget to
subscribe, give us a like,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick byte of cloud storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]